chad cool he gets the starting
assignment this is an opening day
michael mchenry but it's still a big
deal
to kind of lead the way in the second
half it really is we're going to start
out with these pennsylvania lottery
numbers by chad cool and you see those
numbers 4.73 ra that has just trickled
down the last four or five starts i mean
he's really pitched a lot better
utilizing that slider early on to get
the fastball back in the zone that's the
pitch that brings him back expect to see
that early and often and if he can get
that sinker going expect a lot of early
contact
cool ready to rock again his seventh
pitch of this event grounded towards
second base and the all-star adam
frazier just as he started the all-star
game sweeps to his left and throws on
the first to get the out
bounces this ball to frazier one
and how about a double play in the
stretch by nagowski
good start
pirates come to bath
there's a toyota numbers for the
starting pitcher marcus strowman his
19th start
uh like i said he has just been spot on
in the first two and a half months of
the season but when he took himself out
of that game in the first inning four
starts to go with the hip
he really hasn't been the same so we'll
see uh if he picks it up in the second
half he's had the whole all-star break
to rest and uh they certainly need him
the mets that's for sure is about how
far he can go in games turned on that
one into the shift and caught a line
driving out of there
well that's why you have the shift on if
you don't that's a base hit lindordo
frazier was there and got it
teams that use the shift the most
i think the dodgers are the one team
that use it more than the mets in the
national league and here it pays off big
dividends and a beautiful play by lindor
oh snow cone
he made sure he pointed to him said i
got it
he's not even going to look at lindor
though he loved alonzo
so you know that was a hit don't you a
walk and a hit four pitch walk in the
base hit by mcneal
wow
hello
take it
on
friday
and hits this one deep to right
but that's going to stay in fact the
track it dies
for a big second out wow ryan braun
ricky weeks hitting balls in that area
that were just
unbelievable well done
a little tapper he gets mccann two on
nobody out and cool strands them both
nagowski at third defoe at second and
newman at first fraser the lefty batter
against the righty marcus strowman
the other way to left field and there it
is
the two run single for the all-star and
the pirates lead two to nothing
how do you like that
flat out hits there's no better way to
put it i mean ball is up in the zone he
just takes a nice easy approach hits it
the other way
did a really good job by frazier once
again to just play baton ball i mean
he's literally up there playing pepper
every single time he walks the plate
just every now and then he just tattoos
it right there this place pepper puts it
right where you want it how much fun is
that to watch
adam frazier does it again
though here's a great chance
for the mets trailing two to nothing to
get back into it right here
rolled it to second how about this
thank you
room service
four six
three
he knows he can throw it where he wants
to most of the time and he threw a
beauty
they struck him out so after putting the
first two men out on walks
double play strikeout and cool gets out
of the gym
yet again
goal for six runners in scoring position
for the met so far tonight three two
first and third and that one's going to
be chopped
only plays at first
he's play made
run in
and the mets are on the board alonzo
scores rbi will be credited to vr and
the tapper to newman at short
and
hard as they are to come by of late
mets will take the run a beautiful play
barehand play by newman
delivery
endure takes a cut on that one
and a nice jump throw made by fraser did
did he run out of the box
did he it looked like he stopped
there's another slider right down the
pipe
oh oh oh oh oh
i sense an oblique
look at that
oh no
i'm i'm just
i don't know folks and i'm not gonna
speculate but he certainly
took a little grab
and
yep and let me tell you something
oblique that's a long time
well lindor is out
and gourmet is in to play at short and
it was this at bat by lindor
and watch his right hand
right there and a wince
here's the 3-2 delivery on the way that
one's sliced to first
alonzo right there stuck the glove up
and got it hit hard but right at him
look at this we're gonna have the
dugouts empty in here nigowski and
strowman
both dugouts bullpens are starting their
way in
had a little chat
and here come the bullpens a little
tardy
nagowski frustrated that he didn't get a
hit and didn't like
and strowman
wow get the in the dugout
nagowski didn't like the annex
and toward left center field reynolds a
little bit of a late jump but gets there
ryan reynolds
retires mcneil the first out got caught
a little bit in between you see the late
jump but he gets there knowing that he
had to lay out to kind of slow down that
momentum just a really good job once
again of you know doing what he does out
there just making plays he constantly
seems to be in the right position
whether he gets a good jump or not he
seems to get there
drive to right defoe looks we do too
clear the deck with a cannonball
headed toward the riverwalk
wilmer defoe d-i-f-o
gives the pirates a 3-1 lead
he just absolutely annihilates this
slider going in on him he knows it
immediately a little lean back takes his
time around the bases just a really good
powerful strong guy short swing we've
seen him hit the ball over the yard see
him hit off the bench
reynolds launches one to right center
field and clear the deck the all-star
with a cannonball
anchor down
reynolds number 17
4-1 buckos
[Applause]
ronnie he gets that ball up in the zone
the secret 97 look at him hold his hand
he holds the pose that's a beautiful
thing he just holds it i feel like
that's something you would do in
fighting practice in the cage get a shot
oh hopefully tops got that card that's
it
super bowl really amazing
didn't hit it hard
and newman a quick flip to get the added
second how about that play hit very hard
fastball up and in ties him up
newman having the
understand where to throw it that's
awesome yeah because there's no way he's
going to be able to make that throw to
first base
and he just
that's great toss right there and
frazier knowing he has to reach with his
bare hand great job by both these guys
look at newman just getting enough on it
let's get this final out
and there's newman and on the first
raise the jolly roger again over the
mets
the second half following the break
begins
as the first half ended
wins over the mets